ce matin la chaîne réalise un rêve être
au contact des immenses engin qui
travaillent sur le grand port maritime
de fort de france entre les portiques
les chevaliers et les containers par
centaines un chan se sent bien loin de
la routine des soins imposé par son
handicap
alors qu'est ce que tu as vu aujourd'hui
camus
[Musique]
en réalité c'est la deuxième visite ici
sur le site de la pointe des grives
pour ce passionné de mécanique et cette
fois ci il est venu avec d'autres amis
comme lui en situation de handicap
ensemble ils ont pu découvrir toute
l'activité qui rythment leur des hauts
lieux de l'économie de l'île presque en
totale immersion découvrir simplement un
container pour eux c'est grandiose voir
des camions comme lui il est aux anges
vous voyez même voix vous voir vous qui
êtes à la télévision vous voir en vrai
pour eux c'est un grand bol vous voyez
c'est des petites choses mises
bout-à-bout qui leur apportent la joie
et qui leur donne le sentiment et la
conviction qu'ils sont en vie que cette
société est aussi là
une visite qui s'inscrit également dans
une démarche d'ouverture du grand port
de fort de france
il s'agit de rappeler que cette
infrastructure est celle de tous les
martiniquais et qu'elle peut ouvrir des
débouchés professionnels
à tous nous avons une politique tournée
vers l'insertion notamment à travers les
les marchés que nous passons avec les
entreprises martiniquaises nous
favorisons les entreprises qui
pratiquent l'insertion et attaques dans
leur équipe des travailleurs en
situation de handicap donc ça s'inscrit
dans une logique citoyenne du paon à
chan et ses amis sont partis avec des
images plein la tête et l' envie de
visiter d'autres sites de la vie
martiniquaise très prochainement